now let's do Part B Part B find the
average velocity of the particle for the
time period between time 0 and time 6 so
the easy way to think about this average
velocity is that your average or one way
to think about the distance that you
travel sometimes I use D for distance or
you could use s for sometimes for
displacements use but your distance in
general is equal to your average
velocity times time or your average
velocity is equal to the distance you
travel divided by time and so how do we
figure out the distance that we travel
over that period especially because they
didn't explicitly give us the position
function well if you think about it
let's think about the velocity function
right over here which they did give us V
of T and I don't know exactly what it
looks like but let me just draw a
general velocity function right over
here and we care so this is our t axis
and this is our velocity axis right over
here and we care about between zero
between time 0 and time 6 and let's say
our function does something like this we
don't it doesn't really matter I'm just
this is just a general drawing over here
how do we figure out the total distance
over that time well if you take any
small time right over here and you
multiply it times the roughly constant
velocity over that time period then that
will tell you the area the area of this
little column will tell you
approximately will tell you
approximately the distance traveled over
this very small interval of time because
you have a time for time time times an
approximately constant velocity will
give you a distance and so in general if
you take the area under this curve the
area under this curve from 0 to 6 that
will give you the total distance
traveled so D is equal to the definite
integral from 0 to 6 of V of T of this
thing right over here V of T DT and so
if you want the average velocity you
just find the distance which is this
definite integral and then you divide
that by the time or the elapsed time and
the elapsed time in this case I could
actually write times delta T right over
year our change in time right over here
is going to be six we start at zero and
we finish at six so we just have to
evaluate this definite integral which is
not that easy to evaluate analytically
and it's lucky for us that they do allow
us to use calculators in this part so
we'll evaluate it using the calculator
and then we just have to divide it by
six so let's first find out the distance
traveled between time zero and times six
and to do that we can use the TI 85 we
can use
we'll go to catalog this tells us all of
the different functions they have and to
evaluate definite integrals we use the
I'll just go straight to the F straight
to the F this let me go one page down so
this right here FN int so this is
definite integrals so I'll use FN int
you could just type that in but this way
we know we got the case right and
everything so the definite integral of
and instead of instead of output V of T
here but I'll write it as V of X just
because X is an easier key to get to so
we're just if this is we won't take the
definite integral of 2 sine of 2 sine of
e to the T over 4 so let me actually let
me put up let me put another parenthesis
here so it's 2 times the sine of e e to
the T over 4 well I'll just write x over
4 I'll write X instead of T just as just
because it's an easier key to get to and
I'll tell the the calculator that we're
integrating with respect to X and not T
X divided by 4 X divided by 4 let me
close that parenthesis and then let me
close that parenthesis that closes this
parenthesis now I want to close this
parenthesis right over there and then I
have a plus 1 so that is our velocity
function expressed as a function of X
and I'll set hey that the the variable
of integration that we're integrating
with respect to is X I could have put T
there and T there and that would have
been fine and then our bounds are from 0
to 6 from 0 to 6 and if I haven't made a
mistake with the parenthesis this should
evaluate to something so what does it
evaluate to the ti-85 is just chugging
away
nine six so this is equal to this right
over here is eleven point six nine six
so the total distance traveled is eleven
point six nine six our change in time is
six so we just have to divide this by
that we have to divide the total
distance divided by the change in time
and so we just take the total distance
and we divide it by this is just our
previous answer divided by our change in
time so it's one point nine four nine so
our average velocity our average
velocity is equal to one point nine four
nine nine four nine and we don't know
the units they didn't give us any units
here so that's Part B now let's do Part
C Part C find the total distance
traveled by the particle from time T
equals zero to T equals six well lucky
for us we actually figure that out as
part of Part B we figured that out it
was eleven point six nine six so we just
have to write that down eleven point six
nine six and then finally we're on Part
D Part D and I'll do this in a I want to
I'll do this in this blue color
Part D four zero between forty between
zero and six the particle changes
Direction exactly once find the position
of the particle at find the position of
the particle at that time so let's think
about the time when the particle changes
direction and then we will have to
figure out how we can evaluate its
position or how we can figure out its
position at that time so if the particle
changes direction that means that the
velocity that means that the velocity is
going from either a positive velocity to
a negative velocity or negative velocity
to a positive velocity switching
direction so if that would be a point so
if this is let me draw it so this is our
time axis and this is our velocity axis
it must be a point in time so we're
switching directions so if our velocity
function looks like something like that
then this would be a point in time when
we're switching direction we're going
from a positive velocity to a negative
alpha Lassa T or or it could be
something like or it could be something
like it could be something like this
we're going from a negative velocity to
a positive
but the bottom line it's a point where
the velocity hits zero and then on
either side of that we have kind of
switched signs it wouldn't be a point
like this where just is going from
positive to zero and then positive again
this would kind of be something there
just going in the same direction after
pausing so let's figure out let's figure
out where between zero and six our
velocity function is equal to zero and
if we have and they're telling us that
the particle changes directly changes
direction exactly once so if we find the
zero of the velocity function they
already tells that the the particle
changes direction you could test it on
either side to make sure that it's
changing direction but it's probably a
pretty safe bet that if you find the
zero that that will be the time when you
have changed direction so we essentially
just have to figure out when the
velocity is equal to zero here so the
velocity function is 2 sine of e to the
T over 4 plus 1 and we want to set this
equal to we want to find out when this
equals when this equals zero and we want
to get a time that's between zero and
six and so we can subtract one from both
sides you get 2 sine of e to the T over
4 is equal to negative 1 we can divide
both sides by 2 you have sine of e to
the T over 4 is equal to negative 1/2
and we can use calculator here but or we
could just we could just think about it
a little bit in terms of the unit circle
which I always like to do if you're
short on time you might want to use your
calculator but the unit circle since you
know exactly what what you're doing when
you're taking the inverse sine it's a
little bit more useful because there's
obviously multiple there's multiple
angles right over here that you could
put in here that would give you a sign
of 1/2 and you want to make sure that
whatever answer you get it gives you a T
that's in that interval that we care
about so let's think about the unit
circle if the sine of something is
negative 1/2 there's two points on the
unit circle where the sine is equal to
negative 1/2 it's right over here
where the sine is equal to negative 1/2
and you could view this angle right over
here negative
one half you could view this as negative
as negative PI over six or you could
view this as two pi minus two pi minus
PI over six if you want to view it going
all the way around there and then the
other point on the unit circle where
where you are at where the sine is
negative one half is right over here is
right over here and so to get over there
we would have gone PI first you go PI
and then you'll go another PI over six
so this angle right over here this angle
right over here is PI plus PI over six
which is equal to six PI plus PI over
six or seven PI over six seven PI over
six this angle right over here this
would be this would be 11 PI 11 PI over
six if you take two pi minus PI over six
if you wanted to go all the way all the
way around there and and then you can
add you can continue to add 2 pi to
either one of these to get multiple
angles where the sine of that angle is
equal to negative 1/2 but let's just try
let's just try this over here let's just
assume let's just go with this first
angle that's kind of the first angle
that gives us a sine of negative 1/2 and
see if when we solve for T we get a T
that's in our interval so we could say
if sine of this business over here is
equal to negative 1/2 then this business
in here then e to the T over 4 could be
equal to 7 PI over 6
could be equal to 7 PI over 6
based on the logic we just did over here
and then to solve for T we could take
the natural log of both sides
so we could say that T over 4 is equal
to the natural log of 7 PI over 6 or
that T is equal to T is equal to 4 times
the natural log of 7 PI over 6 so let's
hopefully this gives us a T that's
inside of our interval so let's try this
out let's try this out so if we get we
want to multiply 4 times the natural log
of 7 7 PI 7 PI /
six so let's see what we get we get five
point one nine so lucky for us it is in
our interval so this is the T that
matters so five point one nine six I'll
say so this is equal to five point one
nine six approximately so that's the T
where it changes direction but that's
not just what they're asking us so the
particle changes direction and exactly
once find the position of the particle
at that time so this is interesting
because they haven't explicitly given us
they haven't explicitly given us the
position function but we know that the
position function is really just the
integral of is just the integral of the
velocity function we know we know that
the position function X of T is just
going to be the integral from zero to T
of V of T DT plus plus some constant and
they tell us they give us that initial
condition they tell us that X of zero is
equal to two they told us that they told
us that over over here X of zero is
equal to two so we actually know what
the constant is because if you evaluate
this as X of zero you get X of zero is
equal to the integral from zero to zero
of V of T DT plus C and this is going to
be equal to two well this part right
over here evaluates to zero so we know
that our constant is equal to two so we
know that X of T X of T is equal to the
definite integral from zero to T of V of
T DT plus two and you might say well how
do we know the position if we get at a
given time
well we luckily have a calculator that
can calculate definite integrals quite
well so if we want our position at five
point one nine six seconds we just have
to take the definite integral from zero
to five point one nine six of our
velocity function of our velocity
function and add two to that and so
let's get the calculator back out and
let's actually calculate that so once
again let's go to our catalog of
functions I want to go down to the F so
I'll go down to the F I'll go down one
more page no I didn't want to go down
go up a page down two pages actually so
one more okay so there we go this is my
definite integral function and I want to
take the definite integral of the
definite integral of our velocity
function so let me actually let me get
it the velocity function I don't have it
written over here actually we've already
done it up here this was our velocity
function so let me write it again so the
velocity function was to sign two times
the sine of of e e to the and I'll just
use X as my variable of integration X
divided by 4x divided by four close one
parenthesis close another parenthesis
that gets us there now I want to close
that one and then I want to do a plus
one plus one right over there and then I
want to say my variable of integration
is X and I'm taking the integral from
zero instead of from zero to six I'm
taking the integral from zero to five
point one nine six or actually is my
previous answer so I can just say my
previous answer my previous answer and
so now this will evaluate this will
evaluate my definite integral
it'll evaluate this first part right
over here and then I just have to add 2
to it I have to add two so let's add two
and I'll get my answer let the
calculator think about it for a little
bit and then voila fourteen point one
three four so our final position is
equal to fourteen point one three four
if I round it off a little bit